avec ses 33 mille mètres carrés
d'installations couverte
le creps de bourges pourrait accueillir
neuf disciplines dans le cadre de la
préparation aux jo de 2024
parmi elles le cyclisme sur piste le
creps dispose de l'une des rares pistes
couvertes de france et attire déjà les
délégations du monde entier
on a des contacts avec avec le québec
puisqu'ils sont déjà venus ici on a des
contacts avec l'algérie aussi la grande
bretagne se positionne sur un certain
nombre de points aussi on a des
installations qui sont neuf qui sont en
excellente état on a un ensemble de
prestations qui permet justement d'être
pour de la performance un petit peu au
vert tout en étant proche de paris les
zac est pour même se loger sur place
le centre dispose de 118 chambres
réservées aux délégations et sportifs de
haut niveau
alors là on se trouve dans une chambre
type chambre double alors c'est un atout
parce que par rapport à l'entraînement
n'importe quelle installation sportive
au creps est à cinq minutes à peine d
hébergement donc on a une unité de lieu
qui permet de gagner du temps d'éviter
des transports de la fatigue est donc
dans des conditions optimales
d'entraînement performance l'antre du
basket féminin
le prado et ses 5000 places pourraient
également être utilisé comme centre
d'entraînement pour les jo c'est un
complexe qui crée vraiment intéressant
pour travailler il ya la salle de
musculation la récupération les
vestiaires tout ce qui a été tout ce qui
a été refait et est remis voilà au goût
du jour
en tout cinq sites à bourges pourraient
devenir des camps d'entraînement
olympique une vitrine inédite pour la
ville qui espère des retombées
économiques
nous avons un potentiel de restaurants
et de
de d'offre hôtelière qui est
suffisamment importante pour accueillir
l'ensemble des dégâts de négation qui
viendraient ici sur bourges et on attend
aussi une notoriété importante
le comité olympique rendra sa décision
finale
début 2000 21